Hallo.
Und dann haben wir Rechtsanwältin Bea Hubrich hier. Hallo und guten Abend.
Guten Abend.
Die jetzt wahrscheinlich den Rest bestreiten wird. Wollen wir mal sehen. Robin hatte gerade angerufen und hat, hat sozusagen genau die Frage gestellt, die jetzt sozusagen wie von Zauberhamt in den nächsten Teil der Sendung passt, nämlich, dass dieses Freifunk-Prinzip, das haben wir geklärt, basiert darauf, dass sich viele Leute zusammentun. Das heißt auch, dass ich, der ich einen Internetanschluss habe und mir so einen Freifunkrouter hinstelle, meinen Anschluss mit ganz vielen anderen Leuten teile. Und dann kann es natürlich passieren, dass irgendwelche Leute hingehen, sich in den Router einloggen, der von mir betrieben wird über meinen Internetanschluss oder da ankommen über andere Freifunkstrecken und dann irgendwelchen blödsinnigen Kram machen, der vielleicht kriminell ist oder Schweinkram oder weiß ja gar ja was. Und dann bin ich als Anschlussinhaber dran.
Willkommen in Deutschland.
So, Frau Hubrich, es gibt ja etwas, das heißt und das hat man vielleicht tatsächlich auch schon mal in den Nachrichten gehört, weil das ist in den letzten, ich weiß nicht, Jahren sogar schon immer mal wieder Thema gewesen, zumindest in diesen Netzthemenkreisen, die sogenannte Störerhaftung.
Die Störerhaftung ist seit 2006 Thema. Da gab es ein berühmtes Hamburger Urteil und danach haftet der Anschlussinhaber für etwaigig begangene Urheberrechtsverletzungen und muss teilweise nicht unerhebliche Summen an Verwerter zahlen.
Also jemand anderes legt über mein Wille einen illegalen Song runter oder hoch ist ja meistens das Problem?
Ja, ich versuche mich da irgendwie so ein bisschen einzuschränken. Also ich könnte aus dem, was du da angesprochen hast, ganz viele juristische Baustellen aufmachen und besprechen. Das ist auch mal wichtig, dass wir darüber reden. Aber du kannst mich stoppen oder ein bisschen leiten. Ich würde erstmal grundsätzlich damit anfangen. Wenn jemand abgemahnt wird, dann gibt es da in dem Abmahlschreiben, also wenn es einigermaßen sauber gemacht wird von den Abmahlanwälten, die IP-Adresse mit dem dazugehörigen Beschluss von dem Landgericht Köln oder München oder Ähnlichem. Also kommt drauf an, Telekom oder O2, wo man Kunde ist. Und mit diesem Beschluss und der IP-Adresse wird davon ausgegangen, dass der Anschlussinhaber da eine Urheberrechtsverletzung gegangen hat. Und hier an diesem wirklich ersten Punkt entstehen schon sehr große Zweifel. Nummer eins handelt es sich tatsächlich um eine Urheberrechtsverletzung. Also war es eine Datei, die geschützt war tatsächlich auch hier in unserem Kulturkreis. Und die zweite Frage ist die Protokollierung auch wirklich korrekt gewesen. Also die IP-Adresse, die da kommuniziert hat, ist das auch wirklich die, die dann dem Anschlussinhaber zu dem Zeitpunkt zugeordnet war?
Das ist schon wieder viel komplizierter, als ich eigentlich dachte, dass überhaupt Leute besprechen werden. Lass mich versuchen, das nochmal zu verstehen. Also wenn es um eine Abmahnung geht wegen Filesharing, dann wird diese Abmahnung dadurch ausgelöst, dass die Leute, die glauben, die Recht an der Datei inne zu haben, versucht haben herauszuwinden, von welchem Internetanschluss diese Urheberrechtsverletzung durchgeführt wurde. Das heißt, wer zur Hölle hat da nochmal Filesharing gemacht? Dadurch stellen sie sagen, in dem Filesharing-Protokoll, Tauschbörse, wie auch immer, fest, welche IP-Nummer verwendet wurde. Und daraus kann man dann Rückschlüsse ziehen, welcher Internetanschluss das war.
Theoretisch, so ist die Idee, die dahintersteht.
So ist die Idee, die dahintersteht. Man kann diese ersten beiden Dinge schon anzweifeln. Also ob überhaupt das, worum es dagegen überrechtlich geschützt ist und dann, ob das überhaupt richtig ermittelt wurde. Ich frage mich jetzt aber, ist das jetzt relevant für die Freifunk-Debatte?
Naja, also ich komme da sogar noch zu anderen Punkten. Also es geht bei Abmahnungen nicht nur um die Störerhaftung. Wir kommen da hin und wir haben eine ganze Stunde Zeit. Aber es gibt da mehrere Punkte bei diesen Abmahnungen, die fragwürdig sind. Und es beginnt schon bei der Protokollierung der AIP-Adressen beim Provider. Ob das alles so sauber und korrekt passiert ist. Es gab noch kein Verfahren, also ein Gerichtsverfahren, wo ein Provider geladen wurde oder ebenfalls Mitarbeiter von einem Provider und gesagt hat, ich soll das Mikrofon knutschen, sagt der Monoxy, ich bemühe mich. Ja, die Protokollierung ist beweisfest. Ja, die AIP-Adresse, die jetzt zu dem Zeitpunkt protokolliert hat, ist auch tatsächlich dann dem Anschlussinhaber zu dem Zeitpunkt zugewiesen worden. Das ist die erste Frage. Damit will ich sagen, dass viele Anschlussinhaber abgemahnt wurden und gezahlt haben, ohne dass wirklich feststand, dass von diesem Anschluss diese Rechtsverletzung auch begangen wurde. Das ist der erste Punkt. Wollen wir über den hinweggehen?
Wir reden jetzt über eine Sache, die mit diesem Prinzip, dass ich für die Taten anderer verantwortlich gemacht werden kann, eigentlich nichts zu tun hat.
Naja, es geht um Abmahnung generell. Die Störerhaftung ist ein Teil von einer Abmahnung. Das Problem bei Freifunkern ist, dass eine Haftungsgefahr besteht. Und zwar dadurch, dass man eine Abmahnung von Anwälten in den Briefkasten bekommt und aufgefordert wird, eine Unterlassungserklärung abzugeben mit einer bestimmten Summe, die man zu zahlen hat. Das ist das Problem, was Freifunker haben können.
Hat nicht jeder.
Wenn sie den Internet Zugang zur Verfügung stellen.
Ich wollte die ganze Zeit nochmal wieder einhaken. Mir geht es um den Teil vom Freifunk, wo ich meinen Anschluss anderen Leuten frei zur Verfügung stelle, also einen freien Internetzugang haben. Und das hat nicht, wie Monique gesagt hat, das Ganze getunnelt wird, sondern durch einen deutschen Provider rausgeht. Darüber spreche ich jetzt hier und genau da ist Störerhaftung. In anderen Fällen habe ich ja die Störerhaftung nicht. Aber hinter der Störerhaftung steckt eben eine Abmahnung. Ich bekomme eine Abmahnung und da gibt es mehrere Teile, zum Beispiel eben auch die Täterschaft. Also man wird immer wieder darüber hinweggegangen und es wird immer nur thematisiert, dass das Problem nicht Störerhaftung ist. Aber was größer ist, ist die Täterschaft. Das heißt, erst mal wird dem Anschlussinhaber vorgeworfen, in diesem Abmahn schreiben, dass er eine Urheberrechtsverletzung begangen hat und dass er für diese Urheberrechtsverletzung Schadensersatz zahlen muss. Und erst wenn er nachweisen kann, dass er selber nicht Täter war, kommt man auf die zweite Ebene der Störerhaftung. Störerhaftung bedeutet, ich habe daran teilgenommen, dass jemand eine Urheberrechtsverletzung begangen hat. Und ich habe vorher noch versucht zu erklären, dass es oft strittig ist oder man das auch mal diskutieren muss, dass überhaupt diese Urheberrechtsverletzung begangen wurde und Nummer zwei auch überhaupt von diesem Internetanschluss. Also Störerhaftung ist sozusagen die vierte Stufe bei diesen Abmahnungen.
Dann machen wir es jetzt wie du willst und zwar der Reihe nach. So, warum ist es, wie kann überhaupt angezweifelt werden, dass die pfeilgescherte Datei überhaupt urheberrechtlich geschützt ist?
Weil nicht alle Dateien, die man tauscht, urheberrechtlich geschützt sind. Die können dir ja irgendwas erzählen.
Wenn aber sozusagen eine Abmahnkanzlei losgeht und sozusagen Leute abmahnt wegen Pfeilschering, müssen die doch irgendwie sicherstellen, weswegen die abmahnen oder nicht? Die können auch nicht einfach überhaupt sagen, hier, du hast was Falsches gemacht.
Aber das passiert doch ständig.
Das verstehe ich nicht.
Also Leute gehen vor Gericht, aber so funktionieren doch Rechtsstreitigkeiten. Der eine wirft dem anderen etwas vor, dass du hier rechtlich was falsch gemacht hast und es muss geklärt werden, ob das stimmt.
Ja klar, aber sozusagen ein Abmahnanwalt kann wegen Pfeilschering doch nur abmahnen, wenn ein urheberrechtlich geschütztes Werk vorliegen hat, wo seine Lakaien festgestellt haben, dass es in irgendeiner Tauschbörse aufgetauscht ist.
Das sind Drittdienstleister, die für die arbeiten. Und das ist alles nicht so wahnsinnig sauer, was da passiert. Wenn ein Anwalt behauptet, dass jemand anderes eine Rechtsverletzung begangen hat, ist es nicht automatisch so, dass derjenige die Rechtsverletzung begangen hat, sondern das muss erst mal kontrolliert werden. Und deshalb haben wir bestimmte Regelungen, Beweisregelungen vor Gericht, dass es überprüft wird, was vor Vorwürfe eben von einem Anwalt dann damit geteilt wurde.
Ich kann jetzt natürlich wieder nur meine Privatstatistik anbringen. Jedes Mal, wenn ich sozusagen von Abmahnungen gehört habe, dann waren es gingstattdessen sagen Umwerke, die auch überrichtlich geschützt waren tatsächlich.
Aber zum Beispiel gab es ja auch Fälle, wo Leute ihr WLAN verschlüsselt haben, im Urlaub waren und in dieser Zeit angeblich was...
Doch, das ist genau richtig, was Möko anspricht. Entschuldigung, Entschuldigung.
Es geht jetzt gerade, du hast gesagt, der erste Punkt ist, dass man gar nicht genau weiß, ob die Datei, wegen der abgemahnt wird, überhaupt urheberrechtlich geschützt ist.
Das ist einfach nur behauptet, ich kriege einen Brief und da steht es...
Entschuldigung, es geht doch erst mal darum, überhaupt, du hast doch gesagt, das ist das Problem, dass man gar nicht weiß, ob diese Datei wirklich urheberrechtlich geschützt ist. Und das frage ich jetzt, wie sowas passieren kann. Weil die Fälle, von denen ich immer gehört habe, also abgesehen davon, was dahinter immer noch alles passieren kann ist. Wieso könnt ihr denn auf die Idee kommen, wegen einer Datei abzumachen, die gar nicht urheberrechtlich geschützt ist? Das ist ja das, was du gerade gesagt hast.
Also ich denke, es ist einfach auch eine ganz typische und ganz normale juristische, sozusagen von Juristen vorgehensweise, immer erst mal, sozusagen man arbeitet sich da von vorne nach hinten sozusagen durch und prüft erst mal, ist das überhaupt richtig? Ist dieses Abmahnschreiben überhaupt formal richtig verfasst? Wenn nicht, Mülleimer. Ist denn das überhaupt hier jetzt tatsächlich eine uhrhebergeschützte Datei? Wenn nicht, irgendwie Mülleimer. Ist denn das überhaupt mit dem Protokollieren der IP-Adresse blablabla und so gehst du so durch und kannst natürlich jeden Punkt anzweifeln.
Ja genau, das ist die Frage, ob das überhaupt Sinn macht in dem Fall. Also gibt es tatsächlich Abmahnungen wegen Dateien, die gar nicht uhrberechtlich geschützt sind?
Klar, warum nicht?
Genauso wie es Abmahnungen gegen Leute gab, die halt gar nicht zu der Zeit das Internet nutzen konnten, weil sie im Urlaub waren, dass wir dann verschlüsselt haben. Die arbeiten einfach nicht zwangsläufig sauber.
Es ist eine Industrie, die Geld macht, indem sie wie wie früher Notare schicken, die jetzt diese Abmahnbriefe raus, zack, die boom. Das ist also ganz oft ist noch nicht mal eine Vollmacht von dem Rechteverwerter drinnen. Darüber haben sie sich auch Jahre vor Gericht gestritten, ob diese Vollmacht von einem Rechteverwerter drinnen sein muss. Haben die Gerichte gesagt, nein, muss nicht. Das heißt, sowas kriege ich erst in einem Gerichtsverfahren überprüft und meine Pflicht ist es, zu kontrollieren, dass diese Vollmacht vorliegt, zu kontrollieren, dass dieses Werk überrechtlich zu diesem Zeitpunkt an diesem Ort geschützt ist. Es kann ja sein, dass es in den USA geschützt ist, aber in Deutschland, in Europa nicht. Das sind so Punkte, die ich kontrollieren muss.
Und das sind... Ich, wer ist das dann?
Der Abgemahnte. Das heißt, wenn mir jemand eine Rechtsverletzung vorwirft, muss ich den ganzen Weg, so wie Monique das nochmal wiederholt hat, muss ich kontrollieren, stimmt das eigentlich, was mir hier vorgeworfen wird? Und die Störerhaftung ist der letzte Punkt, den ich mir angucke. Zuerst guck ich mir das an, ist das wirklich ein urheberrechtlich gestütztes Werk? Am besten... Also das kann ich alles nur vor Gericht machen. Außergerichtlich haben die das so erkämpft in den letzten acht Jahren, dass sie kaum wirklich Sachen außergerichtlich vorlegen müssen. Also dass sie die Vollmacht nicht vorlegen müssen. Dass sie nicht nachweisen müssen, dass es wirklich urheberrechtlich geschützt ist. Zum Beispiel. Da steht auch in den Abmalenschriften drin. Wir verweisen auf das und das Urteil. Wir müssen das außergerichtlich nicht mehr vorlegen. Das heißt, sie können mit Prozess, also Gefahr, dass ich das Ganze verliere, sie können vor Gericht gegen uns gehen und dann legen wir das erst vor und dann kontrollieren wir das. Was ich sagen will, ist, dass diese Abmahnung an mehreren Punkten wirklich hinken. Nicht erst bei der Störerhaftung, wo wir hoffentlich noch mal hinkommen und darüber dann sprechen, sondern die Abmahnung an sich muss man rechtlich in mehreren Punkten kontrollieren und überprüfen, ob das alles so in Ordnung ist.
Aber du sagst ja auch, vieles davon kann ich gar nicht ohne Prozessrisiko prüfen. Was kann ich denn ohne Prozessrisiko jetzt prüfen?
Einmal die Täterschaft. Das heißt, dann komme ich aus dem Vorwurf heraus, dass ich selber diese Überrechtsverletzung begangen habe. Komme ich da nicht raus, dann besteht die Gefahr, dass die sogenannte Lizenz-Analogie angewendet wird. Das heißt, Schadensersatz muss ich in Höhe von einer angeblichen Lizenz zahlen.
Also Täterschaft heißt sozusagen, wenn ich die Abmahnung kriege, wirft mir die Abmahnung ja quasi vor, du warst es. Du hast das zu sagen, du bist der Täter, du bist der Täter des Fall-Sharing. Ich prüfe die Täterschaft, stelle fest, ich war das nicht. Und dann? Also sage ich dann, ich war es nicht? Oder wie funktioniert diese Prüfung meiner Täterschaft?
Ich muss es beweisen können.
Wie mache ich das denn?
Entweder war ich nicht da, ich war im Urlaub, was total super wäre.
Passiert manchmal, aber wahrscheinlich nicht so häufig?
Wahrscheinlich nicht so häufig. Ich bin ausgegangen oder ich hatte Freunde da.
Also da stehen dann Uhrzeiten richtig mit dran, oder wie?
Genau, genau, richtig der Zeitraum, wo das hochgeladen worden ist. Und dieser Punkt ist wichtig. Der ist sogar wichtiger als die Störerhaftung, weil da mehr Geld dahinter steckt.
Okay, also wenn die Abmahnanwälte sagen, wenn ich ihnen nichts beweisen kann, dass ich es nicht war, also nicht konkret selber war, der da was hochgeladen hat, dann könnte es unter Umständen teuer werden. Wie ist es denn jetzt? Ich war zu dem Zeitpunkt zu Hause, aber ich habe es trotzdem nicht gemacht. Was denn dann?
Dann hast du seit diesem Jahr Glück. Es gibt eine neue Bewegung in der Rechtsprechung, und zwar die Annahme, dass ein Anschlussinhaber gleich der Verletzer, der rechte Verletzer ist, wackelt. Die Rechtsprechung ging jetzt jahrelang davon aus, dass Internetanschlüsse nicht geteilt werden oder zu einem sehr geringen Prozentsatz.
Da kommt dann auf diese Idee, das sind doch nur so komische Hippies wie die Freifunkern.
Also die meisten Leute leben dann eben alleine in ihrer Wohnung und haben keine Freunde und hocken da und mein Internet.
Aber dann ist diese Theaterschaft dann doch nicht mehr so hart.
Das ist ein Amtsgerichtsurteil aus München, wo wir wirklich sehr glücklich sind, dass es das jetzt gibt.
Aber das ist einmal so entschieden worden. Das heißt, das ist noch nicht...
Das dauert halt ein bisschen, bis so die Gerichtsbarkeit die Realität erkennt, dass ja schon seit Jahren Anschlüsse mehrfach genutzt werden in Familien durch Freunde oder durch andere.
Aber was heißt das dann jetzt konkret?
Dass ich dann, wenn ich nicht beweisen kann...
Also nochmal sagen, ich kann wirklich nur beweisen, in Anführungszeichen, dass ich es nicht war, wenn ich nicht an dem Ort war, wo der Internetrouter steht.
Mit dem...
Ist eine Frage.
Ja, also es gibt ganz unterschiedliche Urteile. Erstmal grundsätzlich ja, wenn ich beweisen kann, dass ich mit Person B in Südamerika, in Argentinien unterwegs gewesen bin, dann wird mir das Gericht glauben, dass ich diese Urheberrechtsverletzung nicht begangen habe.
Okay, so, das gibt aber keine Möglichkeit, wenn ich zu dem Zeitpunkt, der in der Abmahlung steht, zu Hause war, alleine an meinem Rechner, dann kann ich halt nicht sagen, ich war es nicht, sondern dann hat der Abmahnanwalt erst mal recht.
Na, erst mal, das wird alles ein bisschen offener zurzeit. Und zwar, wenn da jetzt noch Mitbewohner sind, oder wenn ich mit meiner Familie dann da lebe. Also ich wohne komplett alleine da und habe mein Internet geschlossen.
Wenn du es geschlossen hast, reden wir davon, dass dein Internetanschluss verschlüsselt war? Oder reden wir davon, dass dein Internetanschluss offen zur Verfügung gestellt wurde?
Nee, ich bin kein Freifunk.
Dann bist du Täter, in deinem Fall. Genau, das ist diese, also du musst, also ich kann jetzt mit juristischen Wörtern um mich schlagen. Lass dich jetzt mal. Du musst irgendwie, wenn du diesen, das ist anerkannt von Rechtsprechung, dass einem Anschlussinhaber dieser Vorwurf gemacht werden kann. Was wirklich fragwürdig ist und was ich am Anfang schon erwähnt habe. Und wenn du keine Fakten hast, die du vor Gericht beweisen kannst, dass du nicht der Einzige bist, der das nutzt, dann bist du Täter. Und du wirst die Lizenzen für dieses urheberrechtlich geschützte Werk als Schadensersatz zahlen müssen.
Was heißt, also wie beweist sich das noch jemand anderes, was Internet nutzt?
Also WG-Mitbewohner zum Beispiel, Familien, also diejenigen, die bei dir in dem Haus leben.
Muss ich dann beweisen, dass die zu dem Zeitpunkt auch da war?
Ja, du musst die tatsächliche Möglichkeit, dass andere dieses Internet mitgenutzt haben, zu dem Zeitpunkt, also zu dem Tatzeitpunkt nachweisen können vor Gericht. Und zwar so glaubwürdig, dass du den Richter davon überzeugen kannst, dass du zu dem Zeitpunkt nicht der Einzige warst, der das benutzen konnte.
Und was heißt das dann? Dann ist automatisch der andere schuld?
Nein, nein, nein. Dann kommst du aus der Täterschaft raus. Das geht in dem Moment. Du bist der Abgemahnte und du bist der Beklagte.
Dann geht es erst mal nur darum, ob ich es war oder nicht.
Genau. Und wenn du es nicht warst, wenn du beweisen kannst, dass du nicht Täter warst, dann kommen wir zur Störerhaft.
Ich kann ja noch nicht beweisen, dass ich nicht Täter war. Ich kann nur beweisen, dass noch jemand anders auch da war.
Das reicht.
Das reicht erst mal.
Also Leute, haltet euch einen Mitbewohner.
Genau. Ich kann nicht für alle Gerichte sprechen.
Oder macht euer Netz auf.
So, das heißt, dann habe ich gesagt so, ja, ich hatte aber noch jemand anderes Zugriff gehabt zu dem Zeitpunkt. Ich kann es also nicht gewesen sein.
Es ist noch die ernsthafte Möglichkeit, dass jemand anderes diese Rechtsverletzung begangen hat.
Also das reicht als Möglichkeit sozusagen. Und dann bin ich aber so, dann bin ich raus als Täter. Also dann kann man mir nicht mal vorwerfen, okay, du warst es aber, sondern dann bin ich aber möglicherweise noch störerhaft. Störer, was ist ein Störer?
Ein Störer ist jemand, der sich an einer Rechtsverletzung beteiligt.
Moment mal, ich habe mein Internet-Dings mit anderen Leuten geteilt und da habe ich doch nichts mitgemacht. Also ich war doch nur an meinem Rechner, habe Comics gelesen und der andere hat Gefeilschert. Wieso bin ich da beteiligt juristisch?
Mitstörer heißt das doch sogar ganz korrekt oder?
Du kannst doch durch Unterlassen Störer sein. Also du musst nicht immer nur aktiv irgendjemanden unterstützen, also du musst nicht irgendjemanden bewusst fördern, sagen, hey guck mal hier ist irgendwie auf der und der Website, kannst du da diesen tollen Film angucken, musst du dir aber irgendwie runterladen, ich glaube das Illiga und tralala. Also du musst halt da nicht irgendwie aktiv auf jemanden einwirken, sondern das reicht das Passive und zwar, wenn du jemand anderen in dein Wirkfeld reinlässt, sozusagen eben deinen Anschluss zur Verfügung stellst, dann bist du dann daran beteiligt. Um das mal klar zu machen.
Das heißt, ich nehme mein Internet, mache das auf und stehe nicht die ganze Zeit hinter dem anderen, der das auch noch sagt, nein, du darfst nicht falsch hören, dann bin ich sozusagen Störer.
Ja, schon vorher, in dem Moment, wo du es aufmachst. Also in dem Moment, wenn du dafür sorgst, dass deine Mitbewohner, deine Familie, deine Freunde das Internet mitbenutzen und da irgendetwas passiert, bist du daran beteiligt, weil es dein Anschluss ist. Weil du das nicht unterlassen hast, dafür zu sorgen, dass es nicht passiert.
Das ist nicht ganz so teuer, wie wenn ich Täter wäre, aber es kostet immer noch Geld.
Genau, das ist nicht ganz so teuer, da kann man so mal eins, zwei Nullen wegmachen.
Das ist aber natürlich der Punkt, wo ich sage, naja, wenn ich das für meine WG aufmache, dann kann ich jedem einzelnen die Warte geben und sagen, nee, machen wir hier keinen Fallscheren. Aber wenn ich das jetzt für Freifunk aufmache, dann kann ja jeder, also nicht nur die Leute, die in meinem WLAN drin sind, sondern auch noch die Leute, die dadurch, dass mein WLAN ja mit anderen WLANs verknüpft ist und sozusagen eigentlich ganz viele Leute über meinen Internetanschluss Dinge tun können, da laufe ich ja quasi, also statistisch gesehen, in Gefahr, dass es auf jeden Fall irgendwann mal passiert.
Statistisch gesehen, ja.
Das spricht jetzt nicht so richtig für Freifunk.
Es spricht generell nicht dafür, dass man sein Internet aufmacht.
Eigentlich möchte ich meinen WG-Mitbewohnern sagen, nee, auch meiner Familie nicht, holt mal bitte euren eigenen Anschluss.
Genau, also auch Leute, die mir nahe stehen, mit denen ich gerne irgendwie meine Werte, die ich besitze, teile. Die Störerhaftung an sich ist im Urheberrecht umstritten. Die Störerhaftung ist außerhalb des Urheberrechts gar keine schlechte Idee. Das ist auch altes, altes Zivilrecht. Wir lernen im Studium, dass mit dem Beispiel, ich besitze ein Grundstück neben einem anderen Grundstück und mein Nachbar, der hatte auch ein schönes Haus. Und auf meinem Grundstück ist ein Baum, eine riesengroße Kiefer stattlich. Und beim letzten Gewitter hat so ein bisschen was abgekommen. Und jetzt besteht die Gefahr, dass diese Kiefer umkippt und direkt auf das Haus des Nachbarn. Der Nachbar sieht es. Der kann ja natürlich nicht auf mein Grundstück und diese Kiefer einfach wegmachen lassen. Kostet auch einen Heidengeld. Aber er kann mich als Störer heranziehen. Das heißt, er kann von mir verlangen, dass ich diese Kiefer sicher. Sodass diese Gefahr des Umkippens auf sein Haus nicht mehr gibt. Ist eine gute Idee. Also wenn ich bestimmte Sachen betreibe, wie zum Beispiel ein Auto, was anerkanntermaßen ein Werkzeug ist, was Leben gefährden kann und das auch tut. Oder ein AKW oder ähnliches. Ich muss dafür sorgen, dass von diesen Gefahrenzonen keine Schäden ausgehen.
Okay, aber jetzt ist sozusagen ein Villernrouter weder ein AKW noch eine Kiefer.
Korrekt.
Glauben manche Leute. Aber es hat sich sozusagen noch nicht so ganz durchgesetzt.
Genau. Das Internet ist keine Gefahrenzone.
Mein Lieblingssatz. Ist es nicht. Und zwar, weil es sich ja nur um einen Reinkommunikations- oder Informationsmittel handelt, genauso wie wenig von einem Telefon die Gefahr ausgeht oder von einem Briefkasten, sondern nur, wie ich es nutze. Also ich bin oder vergleichbar mit einer Autobahn. Die Autobahn an sich, wenn die da ist, ist unproblematisch. Also da wird jetzt niemand sterben. Aber wenn jemand ein Auto so gegen eine Person verwendet, dass sie verletzt werden kann, dann haben wir ein Problem. Also nicht die Autobahn und nicht Internet ist hier gefährlich, sondern wie bestimmte Personen die Autobahn oder das Internet nutzen oder womit. Diese Unterscheidung wird leider nicht vorgenommen.
So, aber wenn ich die Richter schiehe, ist es so. Ihr denkt, ja, das ist alles nicht so schlimm. Und mit der Störerhaftung, das ist großer Quatsch. Juristische Realität ist gerade eine andere.
Na, die verändert sich ja gerade so ein bisschen.
Genau, die Auseinandersetzung rechtlich, ob Internet tatsächlich eine Gefahrenzone ist. Also die Frage wurde jetzt rechtlich nicht erörtert, sondern das wurde halt angenommen. Und zwar mit der Begründung, dass eben so viele Rechte von Verwertungsinhabern verletzt wurden. Sie kommen da mit enormen Summen, die sie in den 90er Jahren verdient haben. Mit den Summen standen sie vor Gericht und haben rumgeheult. Das ist unfassbar, wie viel Geld uns hier geklaut wird. Wir müssen irgendwas tun. Und zwar tut man auch nichts gegen die Provider, sondern man tut etwas gegen die Anschlussinhaber, also den letzten Beißen die Hunde. Das hat sich auch rein in einer Rechtsprechung entwickelt, dieses Problem. Es betrifft uns in Deutschland im Moment immer noch. Wir sind in guter Hoffnung, dass es wie in anderen Ländern, zum Beispiel in den USA, dieses Problem nicht mehr besteht.
Oder auch in anderen europäischen Nachbarländern, in die wir zum Beispiel VPN-Tunnel mit dem Freifunk haben, um genau dieser deutschen spannenden Rechtsprechung sozusagen da zu entgehen.
Also das ist der eine Punkt, wenn man Freifunk benutzt, kann man das so einstellen, dass wenn Leute meinen Internetanschluss benutzen, gar nicht sozusagen für Deutsch, also in Deutschland sichtbar sind, sondern erst irgendwie in Schweden oder anderen Ländern rauskommt. Und dann ist das sozusagen eine technische Umgehung dieser juristischen Gefahr. Aber die kann ja auch schiefgehen zum Beispiel.
Ja, da kann technisch irgendwie mal was nicht klappen.
So und dann ist halt die Frage, ich komme immer noch nicht an den Punkt, weil ihr gesagt habt, so also diese Störerhaftung, das ist eigentlich Blödsinn, aber de facto scheint es gerade noch anders zu sein. Wir werden das in der letzten halben Stunde noch klären. Jetzt machen wir erst mal die Nachrichten. Bis gleich.
Egal ob als Sänger, oder Komponist, oder Produzent. Alles, was er anfasst, wird zu Gold. Also Vorsicht, lasst euch lieber nicht von ihm anfassen. Aber angucken könnt ihr ihn ruhig.
Fritz präsentiert.
Dienstag, 16. September. Ferrell Williams, live in der Max Schmeling-Halle.
Die Weltgesundheitsorganisation will mehr tun, um die Ebola Epidemie in Westafrika an den Griff zu bekommen. Die WHO teilte am Abend mit, dass sie ein Notfallprogramm in Höhe von 100 Millionen Dollar auflegt. Morgen soll es dazu einen Krisegipfel der betroffenen Länder in Guinea geben. Guinea ist selbst von der Ebola Epidemie betroffen, genauso wie Sierra Leone und Liberia. Bisher wurden laut WHO mehr als 1.300 Menschen angesteckt, über die Hälfte von ihnen starb. Der Berliner Bezirk Friedrichshain-Kreuzberg muss den Polizeieinsatz an der besetzten Gerthauptmannschule nicht bezahlen. Insenator Henkel sagte in der RBB-Abendschau, dass es nach rechtlicher Prüfung keine Möglichkeit gibt, den Bezirk in Regress zu nehmen. Deshalb müsse die Polizei die Kosten tragen. Henkel selbst findet das falsch. Er warf Bezirksbürgermeisterin Hermann vor, den Einsatz durch ihre Entscheidungsfeigheit in die Länge gezogen zu haben. Dadurch, dass er gut eine Woche gedauert hat, liegen alleine die Personalkosten bei 5 Mio. Euro. Berlins Justizsenator Heilmann ist erleichtert, dass jetzt auch der zweite entflohene Häftling aus der JVA-Morbid wieder gefasst ist. Dem RBB sagte er, dass er der Polizei und den Strafverfolgungsbehörden sehr dankbar ist. Das SEK stellte den 2. Gefängnisausbrecher am Nachmittag in einer Wohnung in Reinickendorf. Sein Komplizen hatte die Polizei schon Anfang Juni in einem Berliner Hotel festgenommen. Beide Männer waren im Mai aus dem Gefängnis in Morbit abgehauen. Sie zersägten die Gitterstäbe ihrer Zellen, seilten sich ab und bezwangen eine Mauer und Stacheldraht. Die deutschen U19-Fußballer sind Europameister geworden. Die DFB-Auswahl besiegte am Abend im Finale in Budapest Portugal mit 1 zu 0. Damit holten die deutschen Junioren nach 1981 und 2008 zum dritten Mal den Titel. Den Siegtreffer erzielte Mukta von Hertha BSC in der 39. Minute. Das Wetter Die aktuellen Temperaturen in Berlin-Marzahn haben wir 14 Grad, im Rheinikendorf noch 19, Ziesa 16, Angermünde 17, Frankfurt 18 und Falkensee 19 Grad. In der Nacht soll es trocken bleiben, bei 16 bis 13 Grad minimal. Morgen wird es dann wärmer, als es heute war. Wir kriegen 28 Grad, viel Sonne und, so weit es man das sagen kann, kein Regen. Stadtverkehr Berlin, Friedrichshain, Karl-Marx-Allee, zwischen Warschauer und Lichtenberger Straße wegen der Biermeile bis Montagabendeinschränkungen Richtung Alexanderplatz. Und zur S-Bahn, zwischen Friedrichstraße und Zoologischem Garten fahren noch bis Montag früh Busse. Alternativ könnt ihr auch auf Regionalbahn umsteigen und ab Montag ist dann der Bereich zwischen Ostbahnhof und Friedrichstraße gesperrt. Wochermehr seid, gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des AirBB.
Und wenn ihr wissen wollt, was heute Morgen bei den Radio-Fritzen am Morgen so los und wichtig war, dann fritz.de slash heute Morgen.
Und dann haben wir an dieser Stelle im Chaosradio noch eine kleine Nerd-News vorgetragen, mitgebracht. Und tatsächlich könnte man an dieser Stelle auch sagen, verursacht von Bea Rubrich, Rechtsanwältin. Hallo und guten Abend. Sie müssten ihr Mikrofon möglicherweise, dann kann man sie auch hören.
Hallo.
Sehr schön. Apple hat Angst vor Ihnen, warum?
Ja, ich glaube, Apple hat tatsächlich Angst zumindest vor einem Urteil. Sie haben am 23.07.2014, also jetzt gerade, ihre Berufung gegen ein 1. 20. ergangenes Urteil zurückgenommen.
Worum geht es, Herrgott, nochmal?
Und zwar Mitarbeiter-Bewachung, Mitarbeiter-Überwachung, illegale Mitarbeiter-Überwachung im Back-of-House. Es gibt in diesen Apple-Läden, Apple-Stores, Mensch, Apple-Läden gibt es einen Back-of-House und einen Front-of-House. Im Front-of-House sind die ganzen Sachen ausgestellt. Da kommen die Kunden hin und gucken sich die Produkte an und kaufen sie. Und im Back-of-House gibt es Genius-Room und Managementraum, wo man sich umzieht etc. Und diese Back-of-House ist nicht für Kunden geöffnet, sondern nur für Mitarbeiter und in diesen Räumlichkeiten sind Rundkameras. Und diese Überwachung durch die Rundkameras wurde vom Arbeitsgericht Frankfurt am Main für rechtswidrig erklärt. Dagegen hat Apple Berufung eingelegt und einen Tag vor dem Urteil über die Berufung haben sie die Berufung wieder zurückgenommen.
Das heißt, Apple ist sozusagen dafür verurteilt worden, dass sie in den Hinterräumen Mitarbeiter wieder überwacht haben?
Genau, dieses Urteil ist jetzt rechtskräftig und sie müssen Schmerzensgeld in Höhe von 3500 Euro an den Kläger zahlen.
Wird das Konsequenzen haben? Weit reichendere? So was wie, die bauen jetzt alle Videokameras ab? Na gut, schauen wir mal. Später dazu mehr. Eine halbe Stunde haben wir noch hier im Chaos Radio im Blue Moon. Heute mit dem Chaos Computer Club und anverwandten Sympathisanten von den Freifunkern. Da sind Mirko, Monique und Bea. Hallo und guten Abend.
Na Abend.
So, wir haben eineinhalb Stunden hinter uns. Es war ein wilder Ritt. Wir haben erklärt, was Freifunk überhaupt ist, nämlich eine Technologie und eine Initiative, um Internet für alle möglich zu machen, also auf eine Art und Weise, die weniger überwacht ist, die vielleicht sogar schneller ist und die dicke Anschlüsse überall hinbringt. Und sind dann in der zweiten Stunde dahin gekommen, dass es so ein juristisches Problem gibt, was generell im Internet existiert, wo man aber als Freifunk möglicherweise auch reinrutschen kann, wenn die Technik mal versagt. Und wo jetzt sozusagen, es gibt eine Störerhaftung. Kannst du noch mal ganz kurz Bea erklären, was Störerhaftung ist? Ganz, ganz kurz.
Störerhaftung bedeutet, ich habe einen Internetanschluss und mir wird vorgeworfen, dass über diesen Internetanschluss eine urheberrechtliche Verletzung gegangen wurde. Ich kann aber nachweisen, dass ich das selber nicht war. Dann geht es da um die Frage, bin ich Störer? Das heißt, habe ich mich beteiligt oder auch passiv an dieser Urheberrechtsverletzung? Ja oder nein?
Also bin ich verantwortlich zu machen, nur aufgrund der Tatsache, dass ich anderen Leuten Internet zur Verfügung stelle?
Korrekt.
Und jetzt, weil ich es richtig mitbekommen habe, habt ihr da irgendwie Zeug gemacht?
Es war mal eine Weile die Entwicklung in der Rechtsprechung. Man ist nicht mehr Störer, wenn man aufklärt, seine anderen Mitnutzer des Internets. Aufklärt darüber, dass Rechtsverletzungen, wie auch immer geartet, durch diesen Internetanschluss nicht begangen werden. Das ist Nummer eins.
Also eine Möglichkeit war zum Beispiel, sogenannte Splash-Pages vorzuschalten, die dich also, das ist in einigen Communities auch so geschehen, du wählst einen Freifunk-WLAN-Hotspot an und bekommst dann erst mal so eine Infoseite. Als allererstes, wo steht, hallo du, schön, hier, das ist Freifunk und so, und irgendwie Fair Use und außerdem möchte ich mich darüber aufklären, dass du keine legalen Sachen machen sollst.
Okay, und dann sagen, dann war ich juristisch raus?
Das war die Hoffnung.
Moment, Moment, das ist einmal diese Informationspflicht, Aufklärungspflicht und die zweite ist eine Prüfpflicht. Das heißt, ich muss auch tatsächlich überprüfen, ob derjenige sich an meine Aufklärung hält.
Das heißt, ich muss sie überwachen?
Also das gibt Urteile, die sind schon wieder ein paar Jahre alt, die diese Pflichten erarbeitet haben. Es gibt kein Gerichtlichsverfahren gegen einen Freifunker. Das heißt, das, was gab bis vor dem 7.7. nicht, dazu kommen wir gleich mit, davor gab es kein Verfahren gegen einen Freifunker. Es gab Abmahnung, sehr viel Abmahnung, aber kein Gerichtlichsverfahren. Das heißt, was ich hier erzähle...
Weil die Abmahnungen immer bezahlt wurden?
Nee, weder noch gar nichts. Wir haben keine Unterlassungserklärung abgegeben und auch kein Cent an die Abmahner überwiesen, sondern einfach nur geschrieben, dass es sich um Freifunk handelt, was Freifunk ist, dass das Internet keine Gefahrenzone ist, dass derjenige nicht Täter war und das halt begründet. Und dann gab es immer mal wieder noch Briefwechsel, teilweise Telefonate, wo mir mitgeteilt wurde, dass Freifunk illegal ist. Also es würde mal gerne dieses BGH-Urteil Sommer unseres Lebens von 2010 herangezogen. Also von Abmahnanwälten, wo sie dann halt gerne behaupten, dass in diesem BGH-Urteil generell die Information gab, rechtlich, dass das Teilen von einem Internetanschluss illegal ist. Das ist aber juristisch nicht haltbar, diese Argumentation. Wir haben jetzt am 07.07. um das endlich mal zu klären und um aus dieser Bedrohung herauszukommen, eine Feststellungsklage bei Gericht eingereicht.
Möchtest du noch mal einen Punkt unterschreiten? Also das ist so, Freifunker sind schon abgemahnt worden in der Vergangenheit. Aber es ist sozusagen immer, ihr habt da sozusagen immer gegenjuristiert.
Gericht, ja, aber eben bislang einfach nur eine Antwort geschrieben, dass wir das alles nicht so sehen und nicht anerkennen und dann immer gewartet, ob jetzt was passiert. Und in halt über zehn Jahren ist halt nichts passiert.
Okay, so und jetzt habt ihr mal gedacht, jetzt wollen wir es aber wissen oder wie?
Jetzt haben wir uns gedacht, wir wollen das Ganze vom Tisch haben. Also wir möchten geklärt haben, dass Freifunk legal ist, dass ich auch in Deutschland wie in vielen anderen Ländern meinen Internetzugang teilen kann, ohne dass damit eine Haftungsgefahr einhergeht.
Also ich kann mein Internet, also ihr denkt, es sollte mal rechtlich festgeschrieben werden, ich darf mein Internet teilen und ich werde nicht dafür verantwortlich gemacht, was andere Leute treiben.
Und die Verfahren sind anhängig. Anhängig ist ein rechtlicher Begriff, das heißt, das förmliche Verfahren wurde eingeleitet und der Gerichtskostenvorschuss wurde auch geleistet und damit wurden die Klagen den Abmahnern, also den Verwertungsinhabern zugestellt und den Prozessvertretern. In einem Fall gab es außergerichtlich dann ziemlich schnell die Reaktion, dass die Ansprüche gegen einen Freifunker zurückgenommen wurden. Und dann sind sie auch am ihre Karteien durchgegangen und haben sämtliche Ansprüche, die sie demjenigen gegenüber, also dem Freifunker, der geklagt hat, ausgesprochen haben, die wurden alle zurückgenommen. Das bedeutet aber erstmal nichts für das förmliche Verfahren, weil es außergerichtlich war.
Das heißt, ihr habt versucht, das mal bis zum Ende durchzuprügeln?
Wir prügeln das bis zum Ende durch, beide Verfahren. Die sind nicht beendet, die sind im Stadium, die Sachen liegen bei Gericht. Und die Richter werden entscheiden, was für ein Verfahren sie jetzt einleiten. Also, ob sie den frühen ersten Termin machen. Das machen sie, wenn die Sache relativ einfach ist. Und sie das dann schnell vom Tisch weg kriegen. Das wird in dem Fall nicht sein, weil du dich erinnerst, in der ersten halben Stunde habe ich ein paar Punkte aufgemacht, die ich natürlich auch in den Klageschriften aufgemacht habe. Das heißt, sie werden das schriftliche Vorverfahren anordnen. Und irgendwann im Herbst frühestens wird es da die möglichen Verhandlungen geben. Wir sind auch vor zwei Amtsgerichten in Berlin.
Aber dann muss ich jetzt auch mal fragen, es gab ja schon so eine kleine Welle, als da irgendwie diese anderen, also die Gegenpartei sozusagen, dieses zurückgezogen hat. Warum seid ihr dann darauf stolz, also wenn das Verfahren ja eigentlich noch total unentschieden ist?
Weil das so eine Richtungsweisung ist. Vielleicht haben sie gehofft, dass wir jetzt die Klage zurücknehmen, was wir natürlich nicht machen, weil wir dann die Kosten tragen würden. Weiß ich nicht, also ich bin wahrscheinlich nicht die Einzige, die Abmahn-Anwälte jetzt nicht für so sehr gute Juristen hält. Also das sind ja alles Standard-Schreiben, die da rausgehauen wären. Vielleicht haben sie da irgendwas erhofft in der Richtung, dass das Verfahren eben dann unter den Tisch fällt oder sowas aber eben nicht ist.
Also eben das quasi als Signal, dass es möglicherweise ganz gut aussieht.
Also als Signal, dass sie sich auf einen Rechtsstreit nicht einlassen. Aber das ist nur einer der beiden Fälle. In dem anderen Fall ist nichts passiert, ist nichts außerrichtlich passiert.
Also dass sie das zurückgezogen haben, das heißt, dann wird der eine jetzt beendet oder ihr macht ihn trotzdem weiter?
Alle beide werden weiter gemacht.
Also die Abmahnindustrie bewegt sich ja auch auf sehr dünnem Eis und das weiß sie selber. Und wenn es halt zu einem Gerichtsverfahren kommen würde, dann könnte halt ihr gesamtes Geschäftsmodell zusammenbrechen.
Okay, jetzt habt ihr gleich zwei am Start. Na da bin ich ja gespannt. Wie sind denn, also ich meine, klar, ihr seht es wahrscheinlich positiv sozusagen die Erfolgsaufsichten, aber wie sicher seid ihr da?
Es gibt so ein paar Urteile, die denke ich schon in eine ganz gute Richtung weisen in der letzten Zeit. Da gab es drei, vier. Das eine war, dass Kaffeebetreiber sozusagen plötzlich nicht mehr in der Störerhaftung waren, dass Ferienwohnungsbetreiber, Hotelbetreiber nicht mehr in der Störerhaftung sind. Das zeigt alles in so eine Richtung. Dann war ein Vater, das war das Biershare, ein Vater nicht für seinen volljährigen Sohn verantwortlich. Da wurde auch das Thema dieser Aufklärungspflichten diskutiert. Dann gab es noch einen anderen Fall, wo es auch einmal ein minderjähriges Kind ging. Also wie viel man muss überhaupt aufklären? Also Erwachsene muss definitiv nicht aufklären. Dann kann ich davon ausgehen, dass die wissen, was Recht und Unrecht ist und so weiter. Und so zeigt eigentlich vieles immer mehr in diese Richtung, dass das eigentlich nicht zu halten ist. Also es gibt immer mehr Urteile, wobei die Fälle ja immer so ein bisschen anders gelagert sind. Und unsere Idee ist jetzt hier, dass für offensichtlich offene, also weil wenn das Freifunk heißt, dann man mal nachguckt, was Freifunk ist, dann ist das halt sehr schnell klar, was hier die Intention ist und dass das öffentlich zugänglich ist und von mehreren genutzt wird, hierfür mal klarzustellen, wobei am liebsten noch einen Schritt weiter. Wir sind ja auch Privatleute.
Also in dem Fall, wenn diese beiden Urteile sozusagen für euch positiv ausgehen, dann würde das erst mal bedeuten, dass es zwei Urteile gibt, die für Freifunker das relativ fest treiben, wo sie dann auch wieder andere Gerichte orientieren. Also es ist dann noch nicht irgendwie Gesetz, aber wäre dann, sagen Sie Wegweisungen. Aber dass das für alle gilt, also ich als Privatperson gebe einfach mal ein Internet frei, das wäre dann noch mal ein Schritt.
Na, das sind ja Privatpersonen. Wir sind ja also die Freifunker, also, ne?
Aber trotzdem, Gerichtsurteile sind immer bedingt übertragbar. Das heißt, wir wissen nicht, was jetzt herauskommt. Das gilt nach wie vor auf hoher See und vor Gericht ist man in Gottes Hand, also.
Wir reden jetzt jetzt zwei Stunden und im Prinzip steht nichts fest.
Ja, aber es werden ja auch viele Fragen aufgeworfen. Zum Beispiel kann man sich fragen, warum die großen Provider eigentlich nicht unter die Störerhaftung fallen. Weil eigentlich sind es ja auch nur, also der normale Mensch, der seinen Freifunk-Router oder anderen Leuten zur Verfügung stellt, den Internetzugang darüber, den unterscheide ich eigentlich auch nichts von dem großen Provider, außer die Größe. Wo zieht man da die Grenze?
Entschuldigung, ich weiß, das wird nicht funktionieren, aber ich möchte jetzt kurz mit gesundem Menschenverstand argumentieren. Also wenn ich als Privatperson meinen Internetanschluss einer Handvoll Leute zur Verfügung stelle und damit nicht mal was verdiene, dann bin ich also möglicherweise Störer. Wenn jetzt eine riesige Firma 100.000 Leute Internet gibt und damit auch noch Geld verdient, also die macht ja quasi, also jetzt mal aus Verwertungsrechte Perspektive, die macht ja quasi Geld damit, dass Leute illegal Zeug runterladen können. Wieso sind die denn keine Störer?
Haftungsprivileg Paragraph 8 Telemedien Gesetz.
Was heißt das?
Dass Provider haftungsprivilegiert sind, Übersetzung, Haftungsprivilegierung. Sie haben eine bestimmte Position in der Gesellschaft inne durch ihre Tätigkeit, ihre wirtschaftliche Tätigkeit sind sie geschützt davor, dass Schadensersatzansprüche gegen sie geltend gemacht werden. Aber jetzt kommen wir gleich zu dem nächsten Punkt. Die Frage ist, wann ist man Provider? Das ist eine große Thematik bei uns. Wann ist ein Freifunk Provider? Also schließlich vermittelt er ja auch den Zugang zum Internet. Und bei § 8 Telemediengesetz ist auch die Frage, bezieht sich das nur auf Schadensersatzansprüche oder auch auf Unterlassungsansprüche? Unterlassungsansprüche, dahinter hinter diesem Begriff finden wir die Störerhaftung. Ich gehöre zu denjenigen, die behaupten, § 8 Telemediengesetz ist so weit formuliert, dass sowohl Schadensersatz- wie auch Unterlassungsansprüche darunter fallen. Das heißt, die Privilegierung komplett für den Provider ist. Da gibt es keine Abmahn-Möglichkeit. Die Abmahn-Industrien gehen aber natürlich nicht gegen Telekom oder O2 oder et cetera, habe Deutschland vor, weil die haben natürlich erstens eine riesengroße Rechtsabteilung und sie können sich Wirtschaftskanzleien leisten. Das heißt, dort hätten schon viel früher negative Feststellungsklagen eingereicht.
Okay, da haben sie sich also nicht getraut. Immer auf die Kleinen. Jetzt könnte man sich vorstellen, es gibt verschiedene Wege, die ihr da gerade einschlagt, die dann möglicherweise diese Störerhaftung rauskippen oder abschaffen, wenn man so will. Könnte man ja auf die Idee kommen, dass dann die Leute, die so mit der Verwertungsrechten Geld verdienen, sagen, na ja, dann lass uns doch mal schnell ein neues Gesetz lobbyieren, dass das wieder alles anders wird. Wie sieht es denn politisch aus in dieser Richtung?
Also momentan ist ja die digitale Agenda im Gespräch, die uns die GroKo hier versprochen hat, also sprich eine Reform vom Internetrecht an den verschiedensten Stellen. Unter anderem auch das Thema Störerhaftung soll hier angegangen werden. Auf netzpolitik.org konnte man kürzlich einen Leak, also eine Vorveröffentlichung eines Entwurfs sozusagen begutachten, der uns so gar nicht gefallen hat und den wir momentan für eine komplette Luftnummer halten. Weil dort das ganze Thema nur für Gewerbetreibende, sprich diese Urteil, die wir schon haben, WLAN-Cafés, Hotels und so weiter, die sollen da sozusagen auch mit diesem Haftungsprivileg und so weiter da ausgestattet werden, die sollen quasi als Provider gelten. Vom Privatpersonen oder freien Community-Netzwerken oder sowas steht da halt leider nichts. Und wir haben auch noch eine viel schlimmere Befürchtung, nämlich dass es jetzt so Richtung Registrierungszwang dann noch geht. Da stehen auch so Ideen drin, wie man muss dann da seine Handynummer abliefern.
Wie als Netzbetreiber? Also ich logge mich bei Freifunk ein und dann müsste dann quasi so ein Formular kommen, hier gib deine Wassromme ein.
Bei uns wird das garantiert nicht kommen.
Was meinen die mit dem Vorschlag?
Also der Vorschlag sagt dann sozusagen, ja, du kannst also du könntest dann hier als Provider vielleicht also erstmal nur für Gewerbetreibende, wie gesagt. Und die Befürchtung ist dann halt, dass man sich dann noch registrieren muss. Also was man mit seiner Handynummer sozusagen, dass man sagen muss, ich nutze jetzt hier dieses Netz von dem Kaffeebetreiber.
Und dann müsste der sozusagen den Datenverkehr überwachen oder wie?
Na der kann das ja dann zuordnen sozusagen. Ja, nur wenn das überwacht. Na ja, erstmal weiß er überhaupt wer, also man schränkt da den Personenkreis schon erheblich ein, wenn man weiß, welche Telefonnummern oder welche Menschen mit welcher Telefonnummern da sozusagen als Täter in Frage kommen bei möglichen illegalen Aktionen.
Okay, also das ist sozusagen dieses Haftungsprivileg für kleine Leute, sage ich jetzt mal, steht also in dem neuen Entwurf nicht drin, aber die Entscheidung, die über diese Urteile gefällt werden, ist quasi zweigleisig, was da gerade gefahren wird. Einmal Haftungsprivileg ausweiten und das andererseits Störerhaftung generell abschaffen oder wie sehe ich das?
In der negativen Feststellungsklage habe ich das aufgenommen mit 8TMG, dass die Freifunker auch Provider sind und unter die Privilegierung von 8TMG ist. Also wir haben in den beiden Klagen die Sachen thematisiert und die Gerichte müssten darüber urteilen.
Aber du hast vielleicht recht. Das eine ist ja, dass die Juristen oder die Gerichte eine Realität schaffen, durch ihre Urteile und eigentlich richtiger wäre es, eben auch politisch ganz klar die Richtung anzusagen und die ist eben nicht klar genug angesagt. Das ist eben noch nicht der eindeutige politische Wille, allen Menschen Internetzugang zu ermöglichen und dafür alle Möglichkeiten auszuschöpfen. So und da geht es genau darum, diese neue digitale Agenda oder diesen Punkt, der auch Reformierung der Störerhaftung da zu beeinflussen politisch. Und da gab es auch mal von der digitalen Gesellschaft ein Gesetzesentwurf, schon etwas länger her, aber das ist im Prinzip immer noch in diesem Zusammenhang aktuell, wo die mal einen Vorschlag gemacht haben, wie denn so ein Störerhaftungsthema zukünftig aussehen sollte.
Wir saßen da auch in Sitzungen in der Politik und haben leider mal wieder feststellen müssen, dass doch der große Teil dort eher die Internetausdrucker sind, die so etwas zu entscheiden haben.
Das Internet ist voller alter Menschen.
Ich will das noch mal wiederholen, wir brauchen diese neue Gesetzgebung nicht. Nach meiner Meinung und anderen Juristen sind auch der Meinung, ich fürchte das wie Monique, dass es eine Angstgesetzgebung geben wird. Das heißt, für Gewerbetreibende, auch Kleingewerbetreibende, wird es vielleicht auch die Privilegierung geben mit Voraussetzungen, dass da eben protokolliert wird, dass man eventuell irgendwelche Verletzungen dann verfolgen kann. Lieber den Achtthemen gehen, so lassen, wie er ist, aber in der Rechtsprechung weiter auslegen. Und zwar bezieht sich die Privilegierung auf Schadensersatz und Unterlassen. Das heißt, jeder Provider ist privilegiert von der Störerhaftung. Er unterliegt nicht der Störerhaftung und Freifunker. Also jeder der anderen einen Internetzugang ermöglicht, ist Provider.
Es wird aber nicht nur Freifunker, sondern auch Hotels, Cafébetreiber, du, deine Oma, jeder, WGs.
Also faktisch wäre dann die Störerhaftung abgeschafft.
Richtig.
Für das offene WLAN.
Genau, wir haben den 8 TMG, der ist wunderbar offen formuliert. Man muss ihn so anwenden, wie er formuliert ist. Und es gibt viele Juristen, die genau die gleiche Rechtsmeinung haben. Man muss es nur vor Gericht durchboxen.
Puh, Gesetzen fallen jetzt irgendwie, dass diese Urteile gehen so aus, wie ihr wollt. Aber die Gesetzesänderung, also diese digitale Agenda, sagt das genaue Gegenteil. Was sticht dann?
Das Gesetz sticht.
Also das, was dann neu kommt quasi. Dann müsste man das alles noch mal von vorne anfangen.
Na dann, naja, die neuere Gesetze sind immer sehr eng, konkret formuliert. Da wird wahrscheinlich nicht viel Raum sein, tatsächlich vor Gericht zu gehen. Gibt es so eine neue Tendenz?
Gibt es schon einen Plan B, wenn das jetzt sozusagen mit der Störerhaftung irgendwie noch ganz schlimm werden sollte für Freifunk?
Andere Parteien wählen?
Zum Beispiel. Der Plan B ist ja sozusagen 99, 9 Prozent der Fälle schon am Start. Das ist ja eine deutsche Rechtsprecher. Um mit VPN-Tunneln ins Ausland zu anderen Providern in europäische Nachbarländer, wo dieser Quatsch halt nicht am Start ist, ist die eine Möglichkeit und die andere Möglichkeit ist eben, der Förderverein Freien Netzwerke, wie gesagt, ist providerregistriert bei der Bundesnetzagentur und insofern auch privilegiert.
Also das heißt sozusagen, man kann über Freifunk teilnehmen, über diesen Verein?
Ja, kann man, genau. Man kann auch routen zu uns, machen auch deutschlandweit einige Communities. Also nicht nur die Berliner Community, weil der Verein ist in Berlin ansässig, tun das, nutzen diese Möglichkeit. Die weiteren Freifunk-Vereine könnten hier nachziehen, können nebenfalls Provider werden. Wir könnten andere unabhängige Provider unseres Vertrauens hinzuziehen. Das müssen auch nicht alle Vereine jetzt zwingen, Provider werden. Da gibt es dann so ein paar andere Risiken, Stolpersteine, die man dann da beachten muss. Ja, ich weiß nicht, ob ich auf die jetzt noch eingehen soll, aber auf jeden Fall ja. Also da gibt es schon Lösungen.
Das ist unheimliche Bürokratie bei der Bundesnetzagentur, dieses Privileg zu bekommen. Das ist ein einfaches Schreiben, das kann man einfach abschicken.
Aber eigentlich wollen wir überhaupt keine Bürokratie, einfach wollen wir nur unser Netz aufbauen und das mit anderen teilen können.
Alles klar, das war's im Chaosradio 203 über Freifunk und Störerhaftung und diesen ganzen juristischen Kram fürchterlich. Bea, Monique und Mirko, vielen Dank. Gibt es noch irgendwas, was man in meinem letzten Satz zusammenfassen kann? Außer wir wollen freie Netze?
Ja, Freiheit ist super toll.
Freifunk Statt Angst.
Ihr könnt diese Sendung als Podcast hören, wird im Laufe der Nacht erscheinen, auf fritz.de, später dann auch auf chaosradio.ccc.de. Ich danke allen Gästen, ihr könnt gerne im nächsten Monat zuhören, da findet das Chaos Radio nur im Chaos Computer Club statt, hier auf fritz.de und in zwei Monaten dann hier wieder auf fritz.de. Mein Name ist Marcus Richter und ich habe nur noch eine Nachricht für euch, lasst sie nicht überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups. Tschüss.